ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
l'activité des entreprises de
l'artisanat et du commerce de proximité
chez dégradées et le président de l'upm
vient d'alerter le président de la
république sur l'inquiétude qui règne
parmi les professionnels les commerçants
et les artisans maillon essentiel de
notre économie connaît actuellement
d'importantes difficultés et demandent
des allègements de charge en lieu et
place de cela vous les attaquer en
remettant en cause leur qualification
professionnelle comme c'est le cas pour
les coiffeurs en effet vous avez déclaré
que vous souhaitiez supprimer la
nécessité d'avoir un brevet
professionnel pour ouvrir un salon de
coiffure
pourtant la profession de coiffeur et
exigeante et complexes elle s'apprend il
m'apparaît dangereux tant pour la
sécurité de nos concitoyens que pour la
santé économique de ce secteur de
rabaisser le niveau de qualification
le brevet professionnel est un gage de
sérieux qu'il faut maintenir
je suis convaincu que ce n'est pas le
bon levier à actionner que celui
d'abaisser le niveau de qualification
pour relancer l'économie
aujourd'hui en france la la coiffure
représente 168000 actifs 6,2 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et emploie
21 mille apprentis monsieur le ministre
vous afficher la volonté de libérer les
énergies chez les coiffeurs supprimer le
brevet professionnel
c'est un acte qui s'apparente plus à de
la démagogie qu'à une volonté de
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes
il est d'ailleurs paradoxal que votre
gouvernement qui nous dit par ailleurs
qu'il met l'accent sur l'école et qu'il
est très attaché aux qualifications qui
laisse entendre que ces formations ne
sont pas nécessaires
que pouvez vous nous dire pour rassurer
enfin les professionnels de la coiffure
ainsi que nos concitoyens
merci la parole et à madame martine
pinville secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce de l'artisanat de la
consommation économie sociale et
solidaire
merci monsieur le président vous même
vous m'interrogez monsieur le député sur
les qualifications et notamment sur les
qualifications professionnelles dans le
domaine de la coiffure
il n'a jamais été question de supprimer
les qualifications professionnelles bien
évidemment très fréquemment et monsieur
le président des coiffeurs je les ai
rencontrés récemment et nous avons nous
l'avons évoqué ensemble
il s'agit plutôt de clarifier les
qualifications dont il est donc dont il
ya besoin pour effectivement pouvoir
s'installer et on peut voir la queue
dans ce domaine notamment dans celui des
coiffeurs il y a des différences il ya
notamment un manque de lisibilité
mais bien évidemment les qualifications
sont toujours nécessaire je pourrais
noter qu'il y a des qualifications
différentes entre celui qui souhaite
installer un salon de coiffure et celui
qui souhaite travailler à domicile
écoutez moi s'il vous plaît mais d'autre
part la semaine dernière je suis allé
rencontrer notamment la fédération du
bâtiment et j'ai pu échanger directement
avec tous ceux qui peuvent s'installer
dans ce domaine là sur les besoins de
qualification et nous sommes en cours de
discussion pour évoquer tous ces sujets
là ensemble mais je tiens à dire que
nous sommes très attachés aux besoins de
qualification ont fait que nos jeunes
par l'apprentissage par d'autres mots
d'autres moyens à l'école notamment soit
en capacité de qualifier pour maintenir
ces qualifications
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement est de
terminer la séance est suspendue